la sécurité sociale raymond barre en a
parlé ce matin au conseil économique et
social cet après midi à l'assemblée
c'est l'un des chapitres de son plan
anti inflation il en sera fortement
question ces jours-ci toujours à
l'assemblée dans le débat budgétaire
la sécurité sociale elle même on ne lui
reproche pas grand chose sinon d'être
l'une des plus perfectionné du monde et
l'une des plus enviés seulement elle
coûte cher très cher même puisque
d'année en année son déficit s'accroît à
tel point que raymond barre a dû
proposer des mesures d'urgence
augmentation des recettes par
l'accroissement les cotisations entre
autres mais cela ne résoud pas le
problème de fond il va bien falloir
transformer notre système d'assurance
maladie
c'est le dossier de ce journal
cette visite aux paroissiens est devenue
familière
chaque français achètent 30 médicaments
chaque année comme toutes les autres
dépenses de santé celle de pharmacie 20
milliards au total par an augmente
rapidement
elles ont doublé en simple elle ne
représente qu'une partie de ce monstre
financier qu'est la sécurité sociale
pour les seuls salariés 180 6 milliards
et demi de dépenses cette année plus de
la moitié du budget de la nation
aujourd'hui les dépenses excèdent les
recettes pour combler le difficile qui
aurait dépassé 13 milliards l'an
prochain
le gouvernement vient de prendre une
série de mesures augmentation des
cotisations par exemple les questions se
posent les français consomment t-il trop
de médicaments
chaque français défend dépensent en
moyenne 350 francs par personne et par
an jusqu à l'étranger bien ça dépend des
pays justement nous venons de faire des
études concrètes afin de comparaison
internationale les récemment nous avons
terminé l'étude avec les etats-unis en
quantité effectivement les français
consomment plus que les américains
meurent dépenses les français ont des
dépenses à ses voisines des américains
des allemands en raison des différences
de prix des médicaments et prix sont
supérieurs aux états unis et en
allemagne
le problème de la santé beaucoup plus
vaste au total la sécurité sociale en
charge quatre types de dépenses
d'abord il ya les accidents du travail
11,4 milliards puis les prestations
familiales 39,19 milliards les retraites
42,7 milliards et enfin l'assurance
maladie 68,5 milliards c'est ce dernier
poste qui crée le plus de problèmes
le chiffre de 60 milliards et demi
couvre uniquement les remboursements des
seuls salariés
c'est par l'assurance maladie que le
déficit harry pour les dépenses maladie
l'hôpital se taille la part du lion
près de la moitié des dépenses les
achats de médicaments viennent ensuite
suivi des honoraires médicaux tous les
pays occidentaux doivent faire face à
l'accélération des dépenses de santé
elles sont difficiles à freiner car plus
on propose de soins puis il ya deux
médecins et plus les dépenses augmentent
qu'on peut observer à l'intérieur de
l'hexagone
des différences encore plus considérable
contre des pays totalement différent ça
signifie qu'on est davantage malades
dans certaines régions par rapport à
d'autres où ce sont des habitudes de
consommation des habitudes locales je
pense que lorsqu'on parle de
consommation médicale
il faut se rendre compte que pour
consommer déçoit il faut que ces soins
vous soit offert qu'il ya une densité
médicale importante qu'il y ait des lits
d'hôpitaux je ne parle pas de la
pharmacie puisque naturellement il est
possible de se procurer des produits
pharmaceutiques dans tous les points du
territoire
et bien il y a actuellement en france un
écart de 1 à 6 suivants la densité
médicale au niveau des départements plus
quel médecin plus elle valable absolue
il n'y a plus de malades soignés
je ne dirais pas qu'il y ait plus de
malades
mais pour bien juger des dépenses
maladie il faudrait connaître les
économies qu'elle jean frère la vie d'un
homme n'a pas de coût et on ne sait pas
avec précision le lien qui existe entre
l'augmentation des soins une baisse de
la mortalité
une chose est certaine la consommation
médicale a triplé en dix ans on ne peut
pas continuer assuré le gouvernement
prépare une réforme de la sécurité
sociale pour le mois de mai prochain
au delà des économies à faire il
voudrait que chacun se sente plus
responsable de ses propres dépenses
sinon le financement de la sécurité
sociale deviendra impossible et personne
bien sûr n'admettrait une baisse de
qualité dans les souris nous sommes pour
ce qui nous concerne
opposé à une remise en cause du niveau
des prestations certains devront
augmenter pour les lunettes pour les
prothèses dentaires notamment et cela
coûtera cher nous le savons où irons
nous chercher l'argent des cotisations
supplémentaires
vous savez bien que d'une façon générale
les salariés protestent
lorsqu'on augmente la cotisation et
pourtant je pense que si l'on veut
préserver cette semaine et social c'est
un des moyens ne dit pas le seul mais
cette année moyens mais de toute façon
si on ne le fait pas par cotisation on
le paiera pas quoi fiscal car l'état
c'est l'impôt échapper à la douleur est
aussi les grandes conquêtes de l'homme
j'aime l'époque moderne parce qu'elle a
su vaincre la rage de dent a confié un
jour un savant c'est une boutade
peut-être mais la douleur s'oublie vite
et il faut se rappeler le prix à payer
pour obtenir cet oubli